the president's approval rating has been
floating between 36 and 40 percent in
most polls for months now we've been
wondering what might push it up what
might pull it down more importantly what
would the implications be of a further
drop in donald trump's approval rating
and we may soon find out because a new
Quinnipiac University poll has a new
presidency low approval rating across
all scientific polls for Donald Trump of
33 percent would 61% of Americans
disapproving of the job that Donald
Trump is doing it is not just Quinnipiac
that is showing record lows even
Rasmussen PAC which always has Trump
higher than anybody else has Trump at
38% which I think might be lower than
Rasmussen ever had Obama during all of
Obama's presidency and Rasmussen is
always the poll that Trump points to
right to prove that he's doing such a
great job he can't do that anymore
there's no one better than Rasmussen Pat
believe me folks have been telling me
about that all the time actually it was
the Mexican president on the phone who
told me what a great job Rasmussen
polling is doing the voice Gallup at 36%
right that's within the margin of error
of 33 percent in the Quinnipiac
University poll and the internals of
this Quinnipiac poll or even more
fascinating white men right that is a
core group for Donny boy white men are
now basically split on whether they
approve of the job Trump is doing 47 48
that is a really important group for
Donald Trump another key voting group
for Trump white men and women without
college degrees remember Trump loves the
uneducated kind of a weird thing when he
said it but he loves the uneducated and
the uneducated voted for Trump in big
numbers 52:43 uneducated non-college
educated whites disapprove fifty to
forty three of the job that Donald Trump
is doing this is president Trump's
lowest approval and highest disapproval
number since he was inaugurated and on
this other quest they asked about
character traits in this poll are you
embarrassed or proud about Donald Trump
being president fifty-four percent
embarrassed 26 percent proud worst score
on any character trait maybe not
surprisingly is level-headedness 71% of
Americans believe the
president is not level-headed 26% say he
is my interest of being talking to
somebody in that 26% who says yeah
Trump is level-headed I think that makes
sense though because while Americans may
not follow the day-to-day of the
Obamacare repeal effort or the Russia
scandal they have a sense of when an
administration is just completely
incompetent and off the rail lying and I
think they they can smell that with
Trump lying is interesting because
honesty was a personality trait that was
pulled here 62% of Americans see the
president is dishonest 34% as honest and
also interesting this is just the best
John McCain Republican Senator John
McCain is now more popular with
Democrats than with Republicans and
presumably it's because of the recent
health care dust-up Democrats approve of
the job that Republican Senator John
McCain is doing 62 28 while Republicans
disapprove of the job John McCain is
doing 49 to 39 stunning numbers Pat I
mean the fact that he is brain cancer
obviously plays some role in that too
but I think Democrats think of McCain
now as what Republicans used to be just
someone with whom we'd have disagreement
you know with Trump it's just completely
different
I completely off the rails insanity
someone you can't even have a realistic
conversation with last thing on this
poll voters now believe two-to-one that
Russia interfered in the election
Republicans don't right so voters
overall 63 to 31 say yes Russia
interfered Republicans say 61 230 no
Russia didn't interfere Republicans are
not surprisingly the only group that
doesn't believe Russia interfered in the
election so what's the implication here
we're now getting into the low 30s which
I've been talking to you about for
months if we see something like 31 never
mind an approval rating with a two in
front of it right other Republicans may
start to throw Trump under the bus and
that will open many new doors here this
includes door opening doors to Trump
being even more erratic and desperate
talking about maybe military action as
we've been talking about with North
Korea or whoever he can find to attack
but it also may make it so that
Republicans stop even pretending to
defend the actions of this president
because if you get too steady 31 30 29
or 28 and I still believe 28 might be
the
bottom-4 Trump at some point here it's
no longer clearly on - in the interests
of Republicans in the House and Senate
to support what you're doing it also is
interesting to wonder what would cause
Trump's approval ratings to go down even
more yeah and when we look at this
latest dip I mean what's happened in the
past couple weeks there's been all of
those firings right of previous of scare
Moochie and he's talked about maybe
firing sessions to the American people
won't have that the other pass tip that
he had in his presidency was when Comey
was fired - right so that the firings
and possible firings aren't helping and
I do think that what's been going on
with the Affordable Care Act repeal has
also not not helped I would say those
are the two biggest factors so far how
divorced from reality or ideologically
committed to Trump do you have to be to
still say I approve of the job that
Trump is doing and a very interesting
note is that in a lot of the polls the
decreased support for Trump isn't coming
because more Republicans disapprove it's
that democratic and independent
undecided who weren't sure if they
approved of him in the last couple of
months
they are moving to disapprove but his
support from Republicans it has ticked
down a little bit but it's still
relatively steady seems like the people
who were giving him a chance gave him
their chance and even the idea though I
think the important point is the idea
that Republican voters are being
enlightened about the reality of Trump
that does not appear to be true how low
will it go I'm still in the 28 percent
camp do you have a number Pat in mind
that you think will be Trump's
presidency low that's where Bush was
right and that's what seven years 21 to
28 percent I think you're right we're on
there 28 you sir you're around there as
well the question is when will it be
next week will it be next month will it
be next year I guess we don't know the
answer but we will see yet another new
low and only 5 points away from what
I've been saying will be the presidency
lo of Trump of 28% send me your thoughts
I'm on twitter at des Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show followed
both of us there today's program is made
possible by taga dabbe the hosting
specialists offering a range of flexible
hosting packages including dedicated VPS
and cloud server options as well as
custom server solutions and uk-based
colocation services for your business or
project
web hosting services support a wide
range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dad has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it go to signup tag
adapt calm /td PS and use the offer code
TDPS 20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration